(upbeat music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two
lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time, I'm Link.
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
Link is pulling back his curtain.
- Uh huh, and you know what's back there?
It's a furry little.
- An animal.
That sounds suggestive.
- Yeah.
- Even saying you're pulling
back your own curtain.
But this is something that.
- Pulling back the curtain
and I'm exposing my kitty.
- Everybody (laughing)
has been speculating,
asking questions about.
Of course, at some point
last year, you did an episode
where you talked all
about the presentation,
the very good presentation,
that your daughter Lily did
in order to, basically ask.
- Sway us into getting a cat.
- To get a cat.
And we haven't really,
we've hinted at the fact
that a cat is present, but this is now,
you're gonna let us
know all about the cat.
- I've been, yeah, we've
been living with this cat.
And I've been taking
notes, I've been observing
what it's, what a cat is like.
What it's like to have a cat.
What impact the cat has
on the Neal household.
Everything was in order.
Every, you know,
if it ain't broke, don't
fix it, kinda thing.
But, you know we have to
bring a cat into the equation,
and so, a lot of question marks.
So, I'm, you know, I'm
on edge for my reasons,
Christy's on edge for her reasons.
But, yes, we did it.
We did get the cat.
Because I'm a Lily person, you know?
I'm decidedly a dog person.
Like, Jade, you know,
is, I adore that dog.
Thought about bringing her in today,
but then I didn't want to sit here
and talk about a cat the whole
time and her to get upset.
- She would have.
- So yeah.
I've spent enough time with this cat
that I'm ready to give you a full download
on what it's like.
And there's still some
lingering questions.
- (laughing) Okay.
Do you think that someone
who is thinking about getting a cat,
that this will be a
useful podcast for them?
- Uh, I think so, yeah.
- And do you think that
after hearing your story,
will there be a definitive conclusion
that they will come to?
That you intend for them to come to.
- Well, you'll have to wait and see.
I think the preponderance
of evidence might lead us
to a certain conclusion, but I haven't,
I'm not intentionally taking
this to a certain place.
As with most all of the podcasts
that I'm bringing something to the table,
I'm just trying to be honest,
and as real as possible about this.
And then, you know, whatever
fallout comes from it,
we'll just have to deal with.
- There's gonna be fallout?
- (laughing) There might be.
- From cat lovers, specifically?
I've experienced my fair share
of fallout from cat lovers.
- Now, you've met this cat,
but we'll wait to interject your meeting,
'cause I kinda want to
go in a little bit more
of a chronological order.
- Okay, all right.
- First of all, I call him the cat.
I refer to him as the cat.
You know, there's been this distancing
that has happened.
It's like, okay, I'm
in observational mode.
I feel like it's his job to win me over.
- That's not gonna work.
- If we're gonna have a future together,
he's gotta put some work in, too.
This is not just gonna be a me thing.
- Cats and work, I'm not sure is a.
- When Lily, you know, as I went through
our response to her presentation,
one of my stipulations was I can exploit
my experiences with this cat
for entertainment purposes in perpetuity.
She agreed to that.
So now, here I am doing that.
- Do you seek approval
from your children for any?
- If it's sensitive, if it's something.
- But in any, my.
- You didn't complete your question.
- Anything that comes into the house.
- Oh, I thought you were
gonna ask do I seek approval
if I wanna talk about my kids on the show.
- Oh, of course I do that.
- Oh, okay.
- But, I'm just saying, if
something comes to the doors
of the house that's not one of my kids,
I feel like that's fair game
to talk about on the podcast.
- Like one of their dumb friends?
- (laughing) Well.
- Man, my kid's got a dumb friend,
y'all wanna hear about it?
(both laughing)
If something comes through my house,
and then becomes a part
of the house, absolutely.
I've got a monetize it.
- Right, yeah.
- And she was on board.
Because she really wanted to get a cat.
So I've been calling the cat,
the cat when I refer to it.
It's not like the cat comes
when I call it anyway.
I mean, when Lily calls the
cat, the cat will perk up,
and sometimes come to her,
but it doesn't happen with anybody else.
But, the cat's proper name is Sokka.
- Okay.
- S O K K A.
- This was the cat's given name?
- He's an orange, no
Lily gave him that name.
He's an orange tabby cat,
and he does have white socks.
His paws, all four of them, are white.
But, he was named after
the comic relief character
in "Avatar: The Last Airbender."
Sokka is the.
- Who is a person?
- He is a person, yeah.
It's the brother who's,
he and his sister found
Aang, the last airbender.
That's a whole other podcast.
But it's kinda related,
because Lily discovered
that "Avatar: The Last Airbender" was on,
they put it on Netflix,
and as a dose of nostalgia
she decided to rewatch it and
then Lando started watching it
for the first time.
And then they just started
begging the rest of the family
to watch it, saying that, you know what,
there's something magical about this show.
You're gonna love it.
And, we,
I actually ended up loving this show.
Some episodes are hit or
miss, but it actually is
a pretty great show,
and it'll surprise you
with the level of depth
with the characters,
the journeys that they go
on, the character arcs,
the humanity associated with
the villains in this show.
And story structure, those
things were really groundbreaking
for a Nickelodeon, what
I'll call a anime rip off.
But I don't mean to offend anybody.
- So it wasn't an anime
that was then overdubbed
it with English?
- No.
- Hmm, I didn't know that.
- I'm even hesitant to use the term anime
because people define it different ways,
and I, you know.
Lincoln is really into
anime, so he kinda likes to.
- Well, people who are
really into it say anime, so.
- (laughing) Okay.
- If you were really into it.
- I know I'm stepping in it.
- But you know what?
Uncle Iroh is one of my
favorite characters in anything.
You don't even know who I'm
talking about, but maybe.
- He's bald, right?
- Uh, anyway, so being
obsessed, and re obsessed
with "Avatar: The Last Airbender,"
she named the cat Sokka.
Now, I call the cat, the cat.
And if I don't, sometimes
I'll refer to him as Thomas.
Which makes Lily feel really weird.
Like, the things that
make Lily feel weird,
like, the way that I can
mess with her, it's so funny.
Like, "Hey Thomas, come here Thomas."
And then I'll, like, pet him on the head.
It'll just, like, make her feel strange.
- Is this because it was the
name of your cat that you had?
- When I was a kid, Thomas was my cat.
It was actually just a tomcat
that roamed the neighborhood.
And he would come into
the shed behind our house.
And there was a big pile of carpeting,
and he would perch on that carpeting.
And I would go in there
and I would pet him.
- And you'd say, "Hey, Thomas."
- I would say, "Hey, Thomas."
- Glad I wasn't present for that.
- You never met Thomas?
- I don't think so.
- There was also a black female cat
which we called Midnight.
And Midnight would not let anyone pet her.
- Another feral cat?
- Yeah, so his name's Sokka,
but I call him Thomas sometimes.
- I don't name the feral cats
that roam my neighborhood.
- I don't either, and I haven't, but.
- One of them came in
my house, remember that?
Walked right across my fricking couch.
- What do you mean?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it caught on the camera.
- Yeah.
- (laughing) That's crazy.
- I mean, he came in my
house, didn't name him.
- I mean, I don't have a
good track record with cats
because Thomas just disappeared
and never came back again.
I got a cat just a few years after that.
I was still young, like in middle school.
Got this little calico cat, and.
- I remember this.
- My mom would let me, it
would sleep in the bed with me,
like up by my head.
And then one day my mom
looked, and she said,
"What is that on your pillow?"
And there was, like, a little worm.
And I think that worm had
come out of the cats anus.
- Well, that's pretty common.
- And so she immediately
gave the cat back.
Like, there was no taking it to the vet.
I'm sure there was a very
simple fix for this, but, like.
- That's like a classic.
- It freaked me out, too.
- It's just like a classic,
late '80s, sort of,
this is what happened when our pets
had problems in the '80s.
- Just give it back.
- Just give it back, man.
Just give that cat back.
Like, now you gotta,
obviously you gotta figure
this out on your own, and fix the cat,
but she just gave it back.
Gave it back to who?
- I'm not gonna, I don't know.
I'm not gonna reveal it at this point,
but Sokka does have a problem.
- Worms?
- No, Sokka has a problem
that has not been fixed yet.
And it needs to happen pretty soon.
And I'm gonna get to
that a little bit later.
But, um, like I said,
I'm such a dog person, you know?
My main concern was, I mean,
I have a whole bunch of concerns,
but my main concern in
bringing a cat into the house
is that how is this gonna affect Jade.
Jade is a very jealous, protective dog.
You know, I bring her
in here, and she, like,
it's embarrassing, she'll like
protect me from other dogs.
And I'm like, hey, there's
nothing to see here, Jade.
Just chill out, you know?
- [Rhett] Yeah.
- I didn't know if Jade was gonna,
'cause it's like, Sokka
came, showed up, like,
such a little kitten.
I didn't know if Jade
was gonna eat the kitten.
Or at least hate the kitten.
You know, I don't know.
- But she had, she actually did,
when we introduced Barbara
and Jade to that cat
in the vlog last year, Jade
did better than Barbara.
- But the theory was that was because
that was in neutral territory,
being at your house.
So I didn't know for sure if
she would be more assertive
and protective of her own zone,
and her own people within her own zone.
So I was concerned about that.
But on the opposite end,
my hope and my vision
is that Jade will love
and accept this kitten,
and that they will sleep together.
- Uh, that's not gonna make a new animal.
- (laughing) I want pictures
of them curled up together
in his plushy bed.
- M'kay, I thought you
were trying to breed them.
- No, I'm not opposed to that.
I mean, if they hit it off.
- That would be kind of weird.
- That'd be crazy.
- A cat dog?
- I mean, like a liger.
- A cog?
- Yeah.
- A dat?
- It could happen.
- I think a cog is a lot better.
- I don't think it could happen.
- No, it'd be sterile.
- I think it can't happen.
Because a cog or a dat,
neither one of those is,
it's not a good name.
It's not like a liger.
- [Rhett] Yeah, it's got.
- Like, oh, they gotta mate
because that name is just asking for it,
they're begging for it.
- I think it might have
something to do with
how far back the lineage was established,
evolutionarily speaking
on the evolutionary tree.
- It probably does, it probably does.
And, by the way, I got lots
of photos and videos of Sokka.
And as I'm talking about
his interaction with Jade,
and what I'm about to tell you,
and basically everything I've
got footage to support this.
So, if you're just listening to this,
go over to the video
version on YouTube channel,
it's the Ear Biscuits YouTube channel.
- Hey, welcome, I'm waving at you.
- We're gonna chock that
thing full of Sokka footage.
Honestly, I was taking a
lot of footage early on
because I was documenting
Jade and Sokka meeting.
And I had this idea, we talked about it,
of, like, doing a vlog on
the Rhett and Link channel
that was just about
introducing Sokka to the world.
That was an idea for awhile.
- Yeah, but we abandoned that.
- But then, the footage kinda
grew, and grew, and grew,
and I didn't know what
to do, do, do with it.
- Well, now we've got.
- I just thought this would be perfect.
- Like a mini documentary about your cat.
- Yeah, the video version of Ear Biscuits
we put visual aids on all that stuff.
So my main concern was them meeting,
and I read up about this.
Okay, you're supposed to put the cat in-
- Butts first, butt to butt.
- Well, in a little crate,
in a little carrier,
put the kitten in there in Lily's room.
And then close the door,
don't let Jade in the room.
And let the cat out of the
crate, and for a few days,
maybe a week, get used
to just that one space,
Lily's room where he does his business,
not in her closet, we
didn't put the litter box
in her closet, thanks for that advice.
We put it in, Lily has her own
bathroom, and it's in there.
But getting used to that
space, getting acclimated.
- And Jade will immediately
know that there's
a cat present in the
house, via the smell alone.
- So, a dog can smell, man.
- Yeah.
- And especially when there's
a big crack under the door,
you can see, like, a paw
coming out sometimes.
She definitely knew something was up.
But she would sit out
there and kind of whimper,
and sniff, and sniff, and sniff.
But, after a few days of
that, stage two was put Sokka
in her, his carrier.
That's the other thing,
is calling Sokka her
for the longest time.
- I did that.
- Because Jade, you're so
used to having one animal
in the house that's a her,
you're not used to a he in the house.
You put him in the little crate,
and then you let Jade come in,
and he's protected in the crate,
and then Jade can
inspect the cat visually,
nasally, but not actually devour.
- And how did that go the first time.
- Jade was really keyed
up, and Sokka just seemed,
like, not too afraid, just kind of like.
I mean, at first, there
was some nose touching.
But then there was, and some cringing,
but then it was mostly
just, the kitten, like,
didn't care that much.
It's, like, very much convinced
that Jade could not get
to him, which was true.
So there were a number of
days of bringing in the dog
to sniff the crate and the
cat in full protection.
But then I'm like, the next
stage is to get the cat out.
- Put it in a dog costume.
(link laughs)
There's multiple steps to this.
- And then just let them meet each other.
So what I ended up doing was,
and at this point I kinda
got scared for Jade.
I was like, I think that, I
mean, the claws on this animal.
- Cat's can hurt a dog.
- Like, could blind my dog.
That would be very upsetting to me.
- Yeah.
- If a Jade eyeball got scratched out
because of, like, how
I'm going about this.
So I would hold Jade in my lap.
I would restrain Jade, and
then we would let the cat
out of the crate, and just
kind of run around the room.
After a few days of this,
eventually it was like letting
them run around a little bit.
Jade would chase the
cat underneath the bed.
But Jade was afraid to
go underneath the bed,
even though she should
totally be able to do that.
- But she wasn't mad,
she was playing with her.
- She was very inquisitive,
yeah, her tail was wagging.
- Like, she was afraid to
go under the bed, period,
or she was afraid to go under the bed
when the cat's under there?
- I think period.
(both laughing)
Yeah, she's got her own.
- She's got some issues.
- Issues.
- Yeah.
But the cat would, I mean,
the cat could not just,
wouldn't go in and just cower.
The cat would keep coming back out
and, like, giving Jade a
little taste of catness,
and then going back in.
- What about, like, the pat, the pity pats
that the cat would do with the hand?
They're really good at
that, did he do that?
- That eventually started happening,
like a little batting of the face.
- That's my favorite thing about cats.
- A lot of that, like, bowing
up and doing the cat pose,
where it's like, the fur
goes up and the back goes up.
You know those, like
the Halloween cat pose?
Or I guess you just call
that the Cat in yoga.
- Mm, Cat and Cow, yeah.
- No Cow, just the Cat.
- Yeah, just the Cat.
- So, over a few weeks
we got them to the point
that they could be in
the same room together.
And they just, they would,
Jade would start coming out,
and then he would start
coming out of the room
and seeing the rest of the house.
And Jade would chase the
cat back into the room.
And then Jade would be happy.
And then after a while,
Sokka would run out,
and Jade would chase the cat.
And then the cat would run away.
And then the cat would come
back, and Jade would run.
And then it got to a point
where they were, like,
chasing each other all
around the living room.
- But this is still playful.
And it's, well,
I think Jade saw it as playful
and I think Sokka saw it as
military training or something.
You know, it was like, "I'm gonna engage."
And everything seems like
training for this cat.
- How do you know that?
- 'Cause he is a wild beast.
I mean, every point of
observation, for me,
supports the fact that this
thing is not tame in any way.
I mean, his pupils
dilate, and they're just,
like, totally black.
Like, it reminds me of the cat in "Shrek."
Remember when he was, like,
his pupils would just dilate,
and he'd go into this.
- That makes him cute, though.
- Oh, no, when he would
do it, it would be like
he entered some fugue state
where he stalks around
the house, and just looking
for the next thing to attack.
I mean, he'll shred the edge
of the couch with his claws.
- But they are less, I
mean, I have to believe
that a cat, a current cat, is much closer
to the original of whatever
was taken from the wild
to be domesticated than a dog is.
- I was talking to Lily
about this last night.
- It's gotta be wildly different.
- I was like, "When I
look at this cat, Lily,
it's like, I can see a tiger in this cat."
- I don't think they
come from tigers though.
- A huge, ferocious tiger.
But when I look at a dog,
the only thing I can see
is a reasonably sized wolf.
You know, it's like, it has the same form
as something that could just,
it's like a zoological tank,
that's what a tiger is, man.
It's a furry tank.
- But, what I'm saying
is I think that a cat,
I think, like, a house cat is,
if you go back 15,000
years, 10,000, 20,000 years,
whatever, there'd be like,
cats that look like your
cat just out in the wild.
Think about a bobcat, right.
A bobcat is not that
different than a cat, right?
But Jade and Barbara look
absolutely nothing like a wolf.
That's what I was saying.
Is that the difference
between what was domesticated
and what we have is so different in a dog.
But there hasn't been nearly as much,
there's also not nearly as
much variety genetically.
I mean, I know there's
like the Maine Coon,
which is like this giant cat.
- Huge, right.
- But just think about
the difference between
a Teacup Poodle, Chihuahua,
and a Great Dane.
They're the same species, man.
But they don't have that kind
of genetic variety in a cat.
And is that just because we
haven't chosen to breed them
in the same way?
I think all it means
is that they're closer
to the original, wild thing, for sure.
- Maybe they're not as malleable.
- And that's why they can just
go live in the wild, feral.
If you put Barbara, I mean,
when we put Barbara outside
to pee in our fenced in
backyard, which, by the way,
doesn't even have real
grass, Jessie's like,
"You gotta keep an eye on her."
- Oh, and you do have to.
- Because-
- A coyote will come.
- A coyote, a, you know,
mountain lion, whatever.
- I think a coyote would get a cat, too.
But they'll put up a much better fight.
- The cat has a better chance to get away.
- A better fighting chance.
- Barbara is like a marshmallow
that just rolls directly
into the coyote's mouth.
- One of the biggest
adjustments we had to make
was remembering to
close the door behind us
when we let Jade out.
'Cause we escort Jade
out to watch for coyotes.
- 'Cause the cat is your prisoner.
- The cat is the prisoner, yes.
I mean, if the cat got
out, the cat got out once,
and immediately darted out the door,
went to the right, and
then went through a hole,
and went under the house.
Just like that.
The only time that Sokka's
been out of the house,
it went under the house immediately.
And, I mean.
- Now how did you solve that?
- Lily brought out some tinkly thing
that it was enticed to attack.
And that's what you do.
I mean, it sees feet
as, like, moving meat.
If you're barefoot, this thing will attack
and decimate your toes,
your heel, everything.
The cat likes to bite everything.
It's just like, it's like a killer saying,
"I choked him just to see what
it felt like to kill a man."
You know?
- You're putting a lot onto this cat.
- He sinks his teeth into-
- You think the cat would eat your foot
if you didn't move it?
- Hell, yes.
- He would keep eating it?
- Well, he doesn't eat
it, he likes the feeling
of his razor sharp teeth
slowly sinking into it.
The worst thing for Christy,
it drives her crazy,
he will prowl up to her
plants, look straight at her,
and then just chomp down on a leaf.
- [Christy] Out, Sokka!
- You know, I mean, Christy's
plants are her pride and joy.
- I've been following on
Instagram as she has come up,
tried different methods to try to keep.
- All types of contraptions.
There's like, aluminum
foil lining the pots,
and she's spraying orange on stuff.
- I'm sure you're, maybe
you're at this point
in what you're gonna say, but,
this is, like, now that
you're getting into
the things that the cat does,
this is where I start to think
about both you and Christy both value.
- Order.
- Order, cleanliness, and,
like, things not being torn up.
- It's hard to train a cat.
- And a cat contributes
negatively to all those things.
Like your plant, your furniture.
Does that stuff go away?
I mean, again, dogs also do this,
but dogs are much easier to
control, so dog's stop doing it.
But, I mean, the cat's only
still a few months old.
- I have the answer to your question.
But first, let's promote some stuff.
Go to mythical.com to get
the mythical travel mug.
Look at this good,
there's a Good Mythical
Morning travel mug.
It's yellow, it's crazy looking.
And then you got this one,
it's just classy looking.
- Yeah, it's just for whatever
mood you're in, you know?
If you're in a mood that,
I'm feeling a little bit cool
and gray today.
- I love it.
- I love it, too.
- It's got a nice cap on it.
Go to mythical.com, drink your boys.
(cup clanking)
He will scale the back
of the high back chair
in our living room like a rock climber.
Just like with his claws.
You know, you can put tape over stuff,
and you can spray stuff on stuff,
but, like, he just
keeps clawing at things.
He hasn't shredded anything to death.
And the type of fabric
that we have on that chair
is the type that it doesn't
show that he's shredding it.
But I don't know, one day
maybe we'll just see cushion.
But we haven't had a lot of luck there.
He just, we have a spray bottle.
The main thing is, like, you
know, Christy walks around
with like, she's in the
wild west, with two.
- Two?
(Link imitates bottles squirting)
With just water?
- She's just like, yeah,
hitting him in the face.
And sometimes, I don't know, he hates it,
but it's not like he runs too far.
He doesn't hate it that much.
I have no complaints when it
comes to his bathroom stuff.
And, credit to Lily, I
haven't smelled poop,
I haven't seen poop or pee.
And she's taking care of that.
- So he's already totally
trained in that way?
- Yeah, all of that's
reliably in her bathroom.
Now, she also feeds him in her room,
and that, the food stinks.
- Cat food's worse than dog food.
- And Jade sneaks in
there and eats all of it.
And then Sokka will sneak
out and eat Jade's food.
I think they've got a system.
- A little battle.
Well, it's just more variety, I'd do it.
- But, watching him play
with Jade is amusing.
That's something that I
have gotten on board with.
They'll wrestle, like I said, I mean,
Sokka kinda thinks it's combat training,
and Jade just thinks it's fun.
But, you know, the claws aren't out,
but they're biting each others neck,
and their hind legs, and
just running around like,
really like two friends.
And it's good for Jade
because she was no where near
as active as she is
without Sokka in the house.
So, I think that's a cool aspect
of it that I didn't expect.
- She's getting her exercise in?
- She's getting her exercise in.
So this is good for Jade.
Jade has accepted Sokka to an extent.
But, I mean, there's still
been a lot of adjustments.
Like, every morning I wake up,
and Lily is sleeping in the TV room.
Because Sokka, when the sun
rises, Sokka will get on the bed
and just insist that Lily
wakes up with the sunrise.
And she said that she'll, like,
put her head under the covers.
And Sokka will, like, dig in there and,
like, claw at her, and just
insist that she play with him.
So she just leaves the,
abandons her bedroom,
and every single morning
she's sleeping on the couch.
And then by the time I
get up at like 6:00 A.M.,
I sit down, I drink my coffee.
I just hear the cat just
like crying in the room.
Meow, meow, let me out,
let me out, let me out.
So I'll let the cat out and
he'll, like, stalk around
and look for something
to sink his teeth into.
But, I mean, you know,
I'm trying to be even keel about this,
I'm trying to look for the things
that are somewhat positive.
- Okay, I'm still waiting.
- Okay, I think I've got something.
So, like, I'm sitting
there drinking my coffee
in the morning, and I'm just thinking,
there is no love in this cat.
It's like, I really do want,
I want the cat to curl up in my lap,
I want the cat to receive
love and give love.
Just give me a little something, cat.
Just, you know, I try to pet you.
Picking him up is like handling a cactus.
It's like, the only prickly parts
that are on his fingertips,
but he gets them everywhere,
and he just wants to get down.
Christy was down doing some
yoga stretches on the ground,
and then she got, like,
her hand got this huge gouge in it.
Just from doing stretches.
- Well, okay.
- Like, bleeding.
- And back in the day,
and I understand why
we don't do this anymore,
I'm sure there's some people
who still do it, but back
in the day they just took
the claws out of the cat, and I.
- That's illegal.
- I understand it's inhumane to do that
because then the cat is no longer,
it's like a body part off of the thing.
You don't want to do that.
But that's what people did
back in the, I remember.
- But they take their balls off.
- I remember back.
- So, it's a little different.
- Well, but taking their
balls off contributes
to less, just, you know,
cats needing a home.
You know, you know Bob
Barker, you remember that.
But, I remember growing
up, if somebody had a cat,
they would specify, and maybe
this is just in my mind, but,
they would be like, "He's
still got his claws."
Like, careful he's still got his claws,
as opposed to all the
other cats that don't.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
And it's like, now you can't even do that.
And I'm not advocating that you should.
But my question is,
it's what I had earlier, which is, is.
- I wish he didn't have claws, naturally.
- But, no, but, is, if you.
- Or teeth.
- 'Cause people give.
- That'd be cute.
- 'Cause people have, like,
the carpet tower cat things.
- We have a couple of those.
- But do they, is there
a way to train them
in the way that you
train a dog to be like,
"You can do your claw stuff on this,
but you can't do it on this."
Or is that, are you gonna get there?
- I refuse to be the one
to do all the research.
- Oh, okay.
- But, I'm like, Lily, you
need to figure this out.
You need to figure out
how to train this cat.
Like, Christy's doing research
to protect her plants,
she'll probably get to these answers.
But, you know, I can only be.
If I start researching it,
then everyone starts looking
to me as the one with
the answers, you know?
- All the cat people listening are like,
"Guys, I can tell you all this."
- I'm sure it's simple.
- "Just google it."
- But it's important to me to not have
to be the guy who's training this cat.
And, honestly, I would
rather have some plants
and some furniture messed up a little bit
than me to have to be
the IT guy, so to speak.
Oh, can you fix my email,
can you fix my cat?
- Now, how has this impacted travel?
Because, obviously, we haven't
really done much travel.
- Next time we travel.
- But, what is it?
- We're not gonna bring the cat.
- But, okay, so you're just
taking it to a boarding place?
- Or get somebody, as he gets older,
get somebody to just come by.
- 'Cause they can just kinda
camp out by themselves.
- Yeah, he's probably
happier that way anyway.
The only way you can
really give the cat love
is if he's asleep.
If he's curled up in a place.
- [Rhett] It's kind of a one way thing.
- You can pet him, and then
he'll keep his eyes closed,
and you can even, like, pet
his chest, and his stomach.
'Cause I'm trying to train him
to let us pet him everywhere.
- Now, when we've talked
about this before.
- And he'll receive that.
- We've talked about this
aspect of cats before.
Many people have pointed out with me
that cats actually are for people
who have more self
confidence, or whatever,
and are less needy, and less narcissistic.
Because dogs give you
that love, but cats don't.
And then other people
have said cat, no, my cat,
I can't remember when we've said this,
but we talked about cats
not being a loving as dogs
and then all of a sudden
everybody started tweeting at me.
- Everybody has an affectionate
cat all of a sudden?
- All of the affectionate cats
that wanted love from them.
So is it that your cat can
grow to be a loving cat?
- I hope so.
- Or is it that your
cat is just a demon cat,
and it will always be a demon cat,
and some cats are not like that,
and it's just on average
more dogs give more attention
to humans than cats?
- Rarely, in the morning, again,
if I'm drinking my coffee,
I let him out of his room,
he's stalking around looking
for something to kill,
after a few minutes of that,
he has hopped up on the couch beside me.
And, like, inspected the couch next to me,
and I notice he's purring.
And I'll like, I'll rub his head.
- That means he wants to eat you, right?
- But he won't come sit in my lap.
I can tell he like it, but I can also tell
that his true passion is
finding the next thing to kill.
So I'm like, I'm saying,
"Look doesn't this feel good,
don't you like this?"
Right here, like, his jawline, like,
he loves to be petted right there.
The purring is such a tease
because, I'm fascinated by it.
It's so calming to me,
I'm drinking my coffee,
I'm petting this animal,
and it's releasing this vibratory hum
that is just, you know what?
If I could change one thing about Jade.
- Give her the purr?
- I wish she could purr.
That's the one thing I've
noticed that I'm like,
man, Jade needs that upgrade.
- You could probably get that
installed in Beverly Hills.
There's probably that option.
- It's kinda like a pace maker for a dog.
Like the vibration chip.
- They can do it, they
can put anything in there.
- In a mobile phone, you just
put that in the dog's larynx.
Or something.
I don't know what makes
it, how do cats purr, man?
It's fascinating.
- I'm sure we could also Google that.
- No, let's not, let's just.
- Speculate.
- Conjecture about it.
- I think it might be magic.
- Is it like a friendly
old man making tea,
like Uncle Iroh making his tea and he's,
like, humming to himself?
(Link humming)
Is it that?
Is is a cat humming a song?
- Well, in my experience they
always seem somewhat content
when purring, so it feels like it might be
that kind of thing.
- I mean, it's.
- But does it feel directed to you?
- It kinda did, because
he came up on the couch,
when I'm petting him the
purr increases a little bit.
- You see, there's
nothing wrong with this.
- When he's just napping,
he's not purring.
- Let me just take a
little aside to say that,
for everybody who said
that, as a dog person,
all that means is that
I'm just more needy,
I'll just say, you're right.
I mean, like, that's why we have a dog.
We have a dog for the companionship
that the dog provides.
We have a dog for the joy
- It makes me so happy that
she insists on being with me.
- And I sit down on my
couch, and Barbara jumps up,
and then looks at me, and
if I don't look at her,
if I don't make eye contact
with her and start touching her,
she's mad at me.
(Link growling)
She'll start barking,
growling, she'll take her hand,
and she'll take her hand,
and first thing she does
is she takes her hand and
she puts it on her head
to show me what she wants.
- On her own head?
- Yes, and then if I don't do that,
she takes her hand and puts it on my hand.
Or takes her whole face
and puts it in my hand.
And I love this.
It brings me joy, there's
a serotonin boost.
Now, I'm not saying
that cats don't do that.
People have shown me evidence
that their cats do do this.
But I don't think there's anything wrong
with wanting that from an animal.
- Don't be defensive.
- I fully admit that's
why I'm a dog person.
'Cause they're more reliably into me.
- If a dog could purr,
it would all be over.
- Well that's where the cog comes in,
and I think we could do it.
- I think it would just, I mean, 'Cause.
- If you put enough resources into it.
- That purring thing is magical, man.
It's like, I mean, it's
like the massage setting
on your recliner but it's a living being
that's, like, well,
he's not in my lap yet,
but, like, I want him
to be there eventually.
- Well, speaking of
eventually, I am interested in
this dynamic that's developing, which is.
First of all, I'm sure all the
cat people are gonna tell us
that things are gonna get better for you,
and the cat's gonna chill out
as it gets older, whatever.
Probably, right? But.
- I think so, yeah.
- Lily is going to college next year.
- She thinks she's
taking this cat with her.
And I just don't-
- What college is that where
you take a cat with you?
- Yeah, I don't know.
We don't know where she's going.
- The cat keeper college?
- We're starting to get
letters of acceptance
from different places.
But, yeah, we don't know,
it's too early to tell.
But I just, yeah, I'm
assuming that the cat is.
- You can't take a cat in a dorm room.
- The cat is not going with her.
And I told her that.
I was like, "Listen, this is a decision."
- She gonna sneak a cat onto a college?
- I have to assume this cat's
gonna be part of our lives,
and she's gonna come back home and say,
"Oh, I miss you so much, but
I abandoned you to college,
and didn't think about that really."
- And then when she graduates college,
or when she gets an apartment in, like,
the last two years of college,
then she'll take the cat back with her.
- Can you believe that we're
even having this conversation?
That I have a child that this
fall is going off to college?
- Yeah, I mean, I can't wait
for my kids to leave the house.
(both laughing)
- It's crazy.
- Just kidding.
But they don't, my kids don't have a cat,
so, it's different.
- Yeah, she did this to us.
She tricked us into this,
and used this whole pandemic dynamic.
It's like, you know.
- Everybody got a little bit weak.
Jessie has really been
pushing for dog number two.
And now that you guys,
we've both been talking
about number two for a really long time.
And Jessie is constantly showing
me pictures of other dogs.
And I love dogs, but I also think about,
just the added responsibility.
- You should do it.
Give Barbara a playmate.
Even with Sokka, that's
such a great thing for Jade.
She's healthier, she's
engaged, she's off the couch.
- Barbara seems happy.
- I don't feel as guilty about
giving her walks anymore.
- You mean not giving her walks?
- Yeah, that's what I meant.
Sokka can do so many
things that Jade can't.
And I'm trying to, the only
way I can really enjoy Sokka
is the purring, trying to convince her
that I'm worthy of his love.
That doesn't feel good.
But just being able to observe
this wild animal in my house,
I'm just trying to embrace
that as kinda cool.
He watches TV.
You know, Jade, in Jade's lifetime
I've only seen Jade watch TV like twice.
It's so strange.
It's like, two times in all these years?
Jade was, there was a dog
barking on television,
now she's looking at it for a second.
But like, she never watches TV.
- Barbara's the same way, and this is not,
first of all, I watch
enough Instagram videos
to know that there's lots of dogs and cats
that watch television
and make real connections
with the things on the screen.
But, I can, like, if I'm not with Jessie,
and we're FaceTimeing,
and Barbara's with her.
- And you talk?
- And then I talk, and
Jessie's putting my face
right in front of her.
- You use the Barbara voice?
- It's like I don't exist.
- Jade will respond to that.
- If I am in two dimensions,
I do not exist in Barbara's mind.
- Jade will hear my
voice and respond to it,
but she won't connect with the screen.
- I think it would be,
a hologram would work.
- I mean, Sokka will watch,
if you put like the whole
laser pointer thing,
or even if light reflects
off your watch onto the wall,
he's going to attack that.
So, again, he watches
TV, Jade doesn't do that.
You know how in my hallway
when you're walking down
into the TV room,
there's that one step up?
Because where my stairs come down,
the stairs don't time out correctly,
so there's like one whole
step up area in my hallway.
So, if you were running at top speed,
you could trip 'cause you have to step up
and then back down into my TV room.
Jade, once it gets dark, Jade will,
if we're all in the TV room,
she will, we'll hear a whimpering,
and she will be four feet
in front of that one step,
and she is afraid to walk up that step
and come in the TV room.
- So she's in the hall, and she's afraid
to go up the step, and
then down into the TV room?
- Yes.
- It's like a barrier.
- It's like a cow and, like,
a cow fence, or something.
I think she sees it as
a big hole or something,
that's my theory.
So, I'll go in there, and
I used to pick her up,
I babied her a lot.
- Oh, yeah, really?
- (chuckling) Yeah.
But I've stopped doing
that, and I go behind her,
and I use foot, and I
nudge her in the butt,
and I make her skid all
the way up to that step
and then jump over it.
Sokka on the other hand,
just kinda walks over it.
Which is kinda normal.
Something else that she does that Jade.
- I'm not impressed yet.
- Oh, you're not impressed?
- I think that's more of a Jade deficiency
than something to be impressed with.
- How about this?
So, this could come as no surprise,
Jade will not walk up
the steps to our bedroom
on the second floor.
- Well, that's because she's seen things.
- Sokka will, I'll be in my
bedroom brushing my teeth,
or whatnot, sometimes I like
to walk around my bedroom
while I'm brushing my teeth.
- So you go out of the
bathroom into the bedroom?
- Sometimes, yeah, I just
brush my teeth in the.
And the cat's walking around up there.
How'd you get up here?
Oh yeah, you walked up the
stairs because you can do that.
- Yeah, that's not odd,
that's just, that's normal.
You've mentioned two things
that are just normal.
- He can open doors.
- Okay, I'm listening.
- It's pretty impressive.
Now, big heavy doors, some of them,
they're old and they don't latch.
So, he doesn't jump up
and, like, turn the knob.
But, a lot of them don't
latch, and he will sit there
and, like, he'll push his
way into rooms through doors.
Jade would never think about doing that.
So, I'm saying he opens doors.
- I think Jade just might be
a little, how do I put this?
What is a good word for this?
- Perfect?
- Dumb. (laughing)
- (laughing) Jade's not dumb!
Jade's timid, man.
- You think, okay, she's timid.
Okay, that's what it is.
- I mean, a part of it's my fault
because she's part wiener
dog, I was real fixated
on not hurting her
vertebrae in her back, so.
You're not supposed to
let a wiener dog jump down
off of couches or beds.
- But she's not really that long, though.
- She's not, she's not.
- So, I don't know if she's
gonna have that many problems.
- She probably wouldn't,
but I was still so concerned
about it that, like, I wouldn't
let her run down the steps,
and so I would pick her
up, and carry her upstairs
or carry her downstairs.
- It's definitely your fault, you did it.
- But the one step, I never
carried her over the one step.
That she just, kinda, extrapolated into.
- Steps are dangerous.
- Steps are bad.
- You taught her steps are dangerous.
- But it's kinda good because
now I can keep her in places.
This cat, you cannot
keep this cat anywhere.
It's just, it's too much.
The main problem with Sokka, is.
- Well, before you get to the problem.
- There's no problems with Jade.
- Before you get to the problem, though.
- Jade's not stupid.
- What you just said
though, it sounded like,
you started and you said,
"Things Sokka can do that Jade can't."
And it was like, and what was I supposed
to think about, like,
what were we supposed
to think about that?
Like, oh, okay, cats are,
is this a competition,
I don't, what am I supposed to think?
- I'm trying to observe and appreciate.
- You're trying to love this cat.
- I'm trying to love the cat, man.
I'm trying to.
- Okay, all right.
But what if the cat will never love you?
- I think it's because of his testicle.
- Oh, okay, here we go.
- He's got one.
- He's only got one?
- Well, there's only one we can see.
And we're pretty sure there's another one.
- Just like an NFL kicker.
(both laughing)
- I bet he could kick a mean field goal.
- This is an inside joke,
and I don't know how many
of you who grew up when
we grew up though this,
but we were told by someone,
and this spread far and wide
in our circles that NFL kickers
had one testicle removed
for flexibility purposes.
- Just to be able to get
that leg back and forward,
to get it way up there.
- And I was like, man, you
know what, it's a serious job.
I guarantee you they would
be willing to do that.
I mean, you got two,
it's redundancy anyway.
- I mean, you know, the
prase, I'd give a left nut
to be a NFL kicker is rooted in reality.
- It has an origin.
- In college it's outlawed.
They had to crack down on it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You have to be a professional,
you had to be getting paid
to kick a football to
have a testicle removed.
- A lot of people, and
there was that one guy,
getting ready for the NFL draft,
he had one more year of college,
but he wanted to go into the draft,
and he got his testicle removed,
and it was like but it
was a little premature.
- No longer eligible.
The NCAA cracked down on him.
- And then he was left in the lurch.
Because he didn't get drafted.
- Couldn't kick the final year,
thought he would get away
with it, but you can tell.
- You can just, out there on the field.
- There's a few inches
of flexibility there,
that guy must, oh, he's missing a ball.
- Plus, if you look
where the testicles are,
sometimes if they're, you know.
That little thing that holds the football?
- The tee.
- The tee, you know when the
college people use the tee,
and they bend over to pick up the tee,
that's when you look at them.
- Yeah, that's when you can tell.
- That's when you look at their testicles
to see if there's two.
- So, your cat is gonna be an NFL kicker.
Why is this a problem?
You're gonna get rid of it anyway.
- I think, what I think
is that the other testicle
is up there, it's just afraid of him.
- You're saying it hasn't dropped.
- It hasn't dropped.
His ball hasn't dropped, man.
- Can I tell you something real quick?
There's a video I gotta show you,
now that you're talking
about testicles dropping.
I saw this video of this bull.
- I'm a bit afraid.
- I saw this video of this bull.
- How?
- On Instagram.
- Oh, God.
- And this bull's balls
were hanging so low,
that it was swinging around
and he was having to step weird
to avoid stepping on his own balls.
(Link laughing)
I gotta show you this video.
- I don't want to see it.
- His balls had fully dropped.
They were about to drag.
(both laughing)
Drag and drop.
- The old drop and drag.
- (laughing) The drop and drag.
- Drop and drag.
- So that hasn't happened to Sokka.
- Yeah, we took him to
the vet, and we said,
"Listen, this cat is out of
control, please tell us that,"
they can't remove the
balls until they drop.
Or, unless they, after a certain
time of them not dropping.
First of all, you gotta
remove the balls before
they turn a year old, and
we're well within that.
- 'Cause they can go pollinate somewhere.
- Yeah, it becomes a problem
with them spraying, or whatever.
- Oh, I'm talking about sex.
I'm talking about the actual act of sex.
It will go have sex with
something and make another cat.
- I know that, but I'm
saying there's also, like,
the cats will spray, I don't even know.
- Spray what?
- I don't know, man, I don't wanna know.
That's why I gotta lob that cat's nut off.
- You don't know anything
about cat's, man.
- I'm telling you everything I know,
and it's a lot.
I've talked for freaking
50 minutes about everything
I know about a cat.
- Yeah, well, true.
- I think half of what
I've said is so trope-ish.
Because that's what I've learned.
- Oh, the cat people are
so mad, at both of us.
- Cat's are just tropes man.
They're just stalking
tropes, that all they are.
But I want it to love me,
but I think the balls have
got to drop and be removed.
Or we gotta, we're gonna schedule him
for exploratory surgery to go up in there,
coax the second one down,
and then take them both off.
And he should mellow out some.
That is our hope.
- You gonna video that?
- Uh, I could.
I don't think I will though.
- I was just asking.
- I'm not going to, no.
- Okay, good, I wouldn't watch anyway.
- Yeah, you would.
I mean, when the bull ball video comes up,
I'm not gonna watch it.
- It's not that-
- Don't reach for your phone!
- It's not like it's gross.
- When did, where you Googling this?
Like, if it just comes
across your Instagram,
what's wrong with you, man?
Oh, look, what is that?
- It's a comedian I follow
that does voices, Tony Baker.
Look at this, man.
- Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
- Look, look at that.
It looks like.
- What on earth?
- It looks like two
baseballs in pantyhose.
(both laughing)
- Oh my gosh.
- It's just like.
- That's a butter sock, man.
You know about a butter sock?
- No.
- My kids talk about a
butter sock all the time.
- I'm sure Tony Baker is
saying something very funny
about it.
Shout out to Tony Baker.
- Man, double butter
sock happening down there
underneath that bull, man.
Shoot.
- So, anyway, that's what
can happen with testicles.
- I knew you were gonna make me watch it.
Man, I'm gonna be going to bed tonight,
and I'm just gonna see
that thing dangling.
(both laughing)
- I don't know, man.
I want to love the cat,
maybe the balls will make a difference.
I'm sure it will only help.
The cat will mellow out over time.
Here's the thing, sometimes
I have a ray of hope.
Because, sometimes he
and Jade will lay down
in the sun on the same floor mat.
- With the lion and the lamb.
- They're not touching, they're
not in the same bed yet.
But they're enjoying
the same patch of sun.
And that gives me a little bit of joy.
They're friends.
- Can I just tell you how
I think this might end?
- Yep.
- This is anecdotal, of
course, based on my experience.
In families where there
is a cat and a dog,
or any combination of
numbers of cats and dogs,
it seems not to be uncommon
that there comes a time
in which people seem to
have a fruitful, loving,
affectionate, two way
relationship with the dog,
who they refer to by a name.
And then the cat, they
refer to as the cat.
- Yeah.
- And the cat does whatever
the hell the cat wants to do.
And the cat is not really
in an emotional relationship
with the humans or the dog,
it's just kind of around.
- Around.
- It's around.
And again, anecdotal, I don't know if this
is representative of the
reality, the general reality.
But it seems that those
families are perfectly happy.
And it seems that.
- Yeah, he'll just move to.
- The cat is perfectly happy.
- He'll move to the fringe of our society.
- But it is a distinctly different thing,
in those scenarios.
I know that there are cats that
are exceptions to this rule.
Again, I've been tweeted many of them.
But, what I'm asking you,
is that if that is what
is in your future, okay?
How do you feel about that?
- It could be worse.
You know, it's not what I'm hoping for,
but it's not what I'm afraid of.
I could be fine with that.
- But what if it's more
about what the cat needs?
- And by the way, it's not gonna keep us
from getting another dog.
'Cause Christy's also
looking at a bunch of dogs
and sending me pictures.
So I think this cat
could move to the fringe.
- Especially if you get another dog.
I mean, then it's outnumbered.
- Oh, yeah.
- And it's like, okay, I
see the writing on the wall.
- But, I'll call him by name, Sokka,
likes Jade, and when one of them gets up,
Jade gets up late, Jade sleeps late,
Jade gets up, and
immediately looks for Sokka
and they, you know, they are friends,
it's working, you know.
So, I don't think we're going
to that fringe territory yet,
and I think, hey, let's
get these balls behind us,
and then maybe some
purring will enter my life.
- What if the purring isn't as good
after the balls are gone?
What if the balls have
something to do with it?
Have you thought about that?
And also, different question.
- I have not heard that, from anyone.
- Do you get to keep the
balls, like in a jar?
- Oh, yeah, like a rabbit's foot.
- Or you can make a necklace out of them.
Or at least earrings, I
mean, that would work.
- I mean, I have noticed
that the ball sack
is very furry.
- They don't cut the
ball sack off, do they?
- I think they do.
Yeah, 'cause then you've just got
this empty sack dangling back there.
I don't think, I've never seen
a cat with just a flat sack.
- I think if there's not balls in there,
it kind of, just sort of,
reabsorbs itself almost.
- You think they suck the?
I will film it, okay?
'Cause I know you're into this.
- Having never done this kind of surgery.
- The way to get Rhett into cats.
Start with the balls.
- Never done this kind of surgery before,
or even thought about it.
I've never done surgery of any kind,
I've never had surgery done on me, but.
- I think they cut the sack, man.
And then they suture the sack.
- Well, I know that in the case of a bull,
a lot of times what
they'll do is they'll put.
- You and your bull balls, man.
- They'll put like a rubber
band of some kind above them
and then the balls just fall off.
Again, that could be like
the NFL kicker thing.
- That bull you showed me
doesn't need a rubber band.
He could use a whole PVC pipe.
- How many times has
he accidentally stepped
on his own balls, though?
Just in that one seven second clip,
he almost stepped on his
balls at least three times.
- You're gonna make Keiko put this
in the video version, too.
- No, I'm not, you can find it.
- Do it, Keiko, we don't care.
Put it in there.
- No, don't, don't.
- The bottom line is, man,
Sokka makes Lily happy.
I don't know why or how, but he does.
And you know what, like
I said at the beginning,
I'm ultimately, I'm a Lily person.
And I will hopefully win this cat over.
And then, maybe it'll
be more of a connection
to Lily when she's off
at college, I don't know.
Maybe there's something to that.
- Well, I think maybe one
day the cat is going to,
you're gonna leave the door
open, you don't mean to.
- Oh gosh.
- The cat's gonna get out, and
then some time is gonna pass.
It might be hours, it might be days.
And the cat's gonna come back.
And it's gonna have
something in it's mouth.
Bird, mouse, gopher.
- Bull ball sack?
- It could potentially.
And it's going to place it
at the threshold of one of your
doors as an offering to you.
And that will be when it has determined
that you are it's god.
And at that point.
- That's what we're after.
- You get the love that you're after.
That your ego needs.
- And until then, maybe I
need to play more hard to get.
- Yeah, don't be too obvious.
- I betcha I could train Jade to purr.
- Think about, if you were trying
to get a person interested in you
that didn't seem interested,
seeming pathetic, and
seeming like a try hard
isn't gonna do it.
I think you've got to be subtle.
And I think you've got
to play the cat game.
- What have I told you about my actions
that you're now describing
as pathetic and try hard.
I just pet the cat when it's sleeping.
- You seem a little too into the purring.
I would play that closer to the vest.
(Link laughing)
- Okay, you know, I think we're
in this for the long haul.
Unless we get, you know, my in-laws,
I can't tell that story, it's too cruel.
(Rhett laughing)
- They lost a cat.
- Yeah, yeah, I'm not, it's.
- It was a strange circumstance.
- It would be funny in a
book written in the '50s.
- Yeah.
(both laughing)
- You know what I'm saying?
It's that kind of humor.
Right, okay.
- Oh, my gosh.
Well, you know what?
Let's give a rec, it's
your turn to give a rec.
- You know, sometimes I like
to tie these things in thematically
to what we talked about.
But, I guess, I mean, you did talk
about how your cat sees
everything as meat.
- Okay.
- As I like to do,
in giving culinary
related recommendations,
my recommendation this week
is the Thermopro digital
instant read thermometer.
Not a sponsor, oops no internet,
I tried to click on it.
This thing is, well, I can't,
- It's just a meat thermometer.
- It's not that much.
The thing costs less than $20.
I wanted to talk to you
about the importance
of having a meat thermometer, right?
And especially these instant read ones.
I'm not talking about one of these ones
that you just stick in there and you wait.
This thing, so.
- I got one, yeah, I use it.
- So, I'll do my, you
know you can't assume
that one steak, or one burger,
or one piece of chicken
is representative of
all pieces of chicken.
You gotta get every one of those
to the correct temperature.
And this little hand-held,
instant read thermometer,
that felt like I said that weird.
Is super easy to manage
multiple pieces of meat.
And when I do my hot chicken,
and I'm frying like, 12,
14 thighs at the same time.
- You don't wanna
overcook anything, period.
- You can't make assumptions, man.
You let the robot do the work.
I mean, yes, I know your
grandma didn't use one of these,
and she went by her eye.
But that's why your grandma
had dry ass chicken.
You know what I'm saying?
- The meat guys who talk about this stuff,
they're all pro thermometer.
Even the, like the charcoal that I buy.
Like, high dollar charcoal.
It tells you that, you know,
get a good meat thermometer.
- It's a piece of
information that will help
with the final product.
- There ain't no shame
in it's what I'm saying.
- And it doesn't make you a sucka,
it makes your meat better.
So anyway, and this is one
that has worked for me,
I've got two of them.
- Just, here's my piece of advice, though.
Don't accidentally put it on
Celsius, and then cook to that.
- Yeah, that would be, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause, 165 degree chicken, in Celsius.
- I don't even think you,
I'm not sure you can.
- It's not even possible, but
if you're waiting for that.
- It probably is possible.
- You're gonna burn your
chicken in the process.
- It will be burnt.
- And I've been baffled a few times.
It's like, damn, I knew this was done.
And it's like, oh, I gotta
toggle to fahrenheit.
- And, let me just say,
this does not replace
the thermometer that you leave
in the larger pieces of meat.
I don't do, like, a pork butt,
and do the instant read thermometer.
- Piece of advice about
that, don't eat that.
Make sure you take it out of the meat
before you eat the meat.
- And do not trust pop out
thermometers in Turkey breast.
Those don't work, they're not reliable.
- Now we're in rant territory.
Are you, just, any meat thermometer,
or that one specifically?
- The Thermopro, not a sponsor,
I think it might be Amazon's choice,
and that's probably why I got it.
- It works.
- But, it works for me.
- It's got a fold out probe.
- Yeah, it's orange, it's easy to see.
- Nice.
LED backlight, when it's
dark out there on the grill?
- Yeah, it's got a light button.
- You gotta have it all.
#EarBiscuits and let us know,
y'all cat people are gonna
come out of the woodwork
and school us.
- Please be gentle with us.
- Let's do it, we like that engagement.
- Treat us like a ball of yarn, okay?
- We like that engagement.
To watch more Ear Biscuits click
on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.
(upbeat music)